the jurgen experience elon's a [ __ ]
wizard man yeah i'm really interested to
see what he does with twitter
because he bought nine percent of time
oh that's right i read an article today
though i didn't read the article excuse
me i read a headline today that said
that uh he might have done something
illegal
by buying that stock
oh really
yeah but like but
what is that what could you have done
i don't understand that
what um what wasn't interested enough to
read what was his motivation the
disclosure of
the
purchase
the disclosure of the purchase that he
disclosed it that's what it's the timing
of the disclosure it says yeah
i think you know how is that when you
make a giant purchase like that
not disclosing it in a certain amount of
time
can affect things
oh it's like affect like how other
people buy it sure um or sell it or do
whatever right affect the stock price
yeah i'm interested to see because uh i
hear they're going to put an edit button
now
because that was one of the things that
he suggested and he made a poll do you
think twitter should have an edit button
and he said yes
who edits what
you whether you can edit it like you
write something and you write 1945 but
you meant 1965. like [ __ ]
you have to delete the tweet and start
all over again
and he wants the he was like
made a poll should twitter have an edit
button and the vast majority of people
said yes so let's see if they implement
that
okay it's a 50-year-old law that
requires that investors notify the
securities and exchange commission when
they surpass a 5 stake in a company musk
reached that benchmark on march 14th
according to the filings but he made his
public disclosure only monday
that sounds like a
minor
in between he continued to buy stock at
the price of around 39 dollars per share
bringing his total stake to 9.2 percent
after his disclosure disclosure twitter
share price rose roughly 30 percent and
is now above 50 per show
yeah yeah so basically if he had
disclosed earlier that he was buying it
the price would have
risen faster yes
got it maybe that would have been bad
for him because he wouldn't be able to
get it at the same rate
yeah exactly if he
if he's actually listened to so i don't
know like how much
power a person who's worth nine percent
has over a company well he's the biggest
uh owner right the biggest stakeholder
shareholder but if he
did they have to listen to him though
you know what i'm saying like do they
have to listen to him in terms of like
whether they want to ban people whether
they want to have an edit button whether
or not they want to apply the principles
of the first amendment to something like
twitter right well maybe it's the it's
the fear that if he were to dump all the
stock
it would hurt the price so they want to
keep him happy
i was having a conversation with a
couple friends yesterday about this and
one of them was dealing with uh comments
on another social media platform
and what they were saying was that
you know
what twitter does by banning people and
censoring people is definitely bad but
there are some [ __ ] horrible people
that were banned by twitter that are now
ruining these other social media apps
and they were explaining to me like
what's happening and how these people
comment on these other apps and about
how toxic they are and about they have
like a whole group of people that have
also been banned that find these new
social media apps and that's that's
where they congregate and hang out and
that's their community now and it's just
it's just chernobyl this is toxic what
are the other apps well there's a
shitload of them i don't want to name
the one they're like this person was
talking to me about okay specifically
because i don't want to [ __ ] up because
i i think i believe in these other apps
i believe in
all these other alternative platforms
and i think that there's great value in
having competitors whether it's to
twitter or to youtube or to any of these
facebook and these
giant
huge companies that have a massive
pipeline to the consciousness of the
world because the what the ability to
distribute information on twitter or on
facebook or like
that is unprecedented there's never been
a thing like that where privately owned
company has the ability to get ideas out
there that can
change the way elections are run to
change the way so many things are
thought of in this country
i think we need alternatives and i think
we need alternatives that adhere to free
speech but the problem is when they've
got these
shitty people that they've kicked off of
these other platforms like twitter
because twitter is pretty
ruthless about it then they go to these
other places and they run amok
and then like hey free speech you need
free speech but then there's they're
organizing harassment campaigns and
[ __ ] with people and targeting them
all day long and constantly commenting
on them and you're like
i don't know if that's good either yeah
you know that would make me not want to
go there if i that was i was this person
so like but i don't like what twitter
did i don't think twitter should have
banned trump
i don't think i think that was a
terrible idea it's a terrible precedent
to set that you can decide that you
don't like a guy who's a [ __ ] sitting
president of the united states at the
time and kick him off your platform
because you don't like the things he's
saying